we are continuing tonight
this evening in our journey through
zadil mahad
or the summary of zadil
with annotations by myself
that i have collected from various
scholars throughout
the years
this book is
a very unique and dynamic book
because if you were to ask me
what is about
the name itself is very interesting
the name that he chose for this book is
provisions to be taken for the hereafter
from the traditions the ways the sunan
of the best of the servants of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
reference to the prophet muhammad
so if you were to ask what is that about
what is its topic
what is the topic that it deals with i
would say
that it is
all the provisions that we could hope to
take
from the legacy and the lifetime and the
traditions
of our prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
to prepare ourselves for meeting allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
this is the
topic now that's of course a very broad
topic
and zadil
it doesn't just have an explanation of
the sunnah
it also is a compilation of the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
it's also a book that harmonizes and
puts into context
all of his sunnah or the majority of it
it also is a collection of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
statements of his actions
of his habits etc
it's also a compilation of what other
scholars of islam historically have had
to say
with regards to this great topic
and also it documents the history
or we should say the most relevant
history
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to us
what does that mean the most relevant
history
well most books of biography
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's books of
history that deal with the prophet
salallahu
deal with everything having to do
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
that is historically recorded and
oftentimes that is
indiscriminate of that which is
authentic or inauthentic
so a historian is very different than a
muhaddith
and we have to keep this in mind a
historian
compiles all that was said
a historian doesn't usually
spend time authenticating
or
or deeming inauthentic any of the
information that here
compiles historians usually
they compile when it comes to
sifting through and categorizing
these different events
categorizing the authentic
and distinguishing it from the
inauthentic this usually goes to the
scholars of hadith and athar
this is usually their field right
though there are scholars that
dabble in both such as ibn kathir and
bingerier both of them do this
even cathy are more so than even
now with regards to
the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam or should i say the
seerah
the biography most books of biography
will deal with
anything having to do with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
from the time he was born until the time
he passed away
and usually a prelude of before he was
born
what the state of affairs was what
the
political arena looked what the
social fabric looked like
what the governments and so forth that
were going on
and different political atmosphere at
the time
to give some context into his birth
also a lot of books of seerah deal with
his life before he was a prophet
but again remember that this book is
called
zadil it is the book of
provisions for the day of the great
appointment
right and so
what is relevant to us as servants of
allah
with regards to the prophet salallahu
is after he was appointed as a prophet
from the moment he was made a prophet
until the end of his life
not before because before he was a
prophet yes
it gives context and it leads up but it
is not as
relevant to the rest of us
because his he was not a prophet yet
prior to being appointed as a prophet
and made aware of it at the age of 40.
and so whatever may have occurred prior
to him being appointed as a prophet
while they are anecdotal
instances of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
preserving him and protecting him and so
on and so forth
they are not relevant to us with regards
to
legislation of course it's relevant to
us
on an intellectual
under an intellectual light under a
muslim a muslim would want to know
however it is not relevant in the
form of teshriya
taking laws and taking commandments and
prohibitions and so forth this is to be
taken
after he was appointed as a prophet
and so for this reason
ibn al-qaeda does not mention this era
before he was a prophet rather his
portion of the book which is
historically as it's been in print the
third volume of zed and mahad
this third volume has usually concerned
itself with
with the moment that jibril came to the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and appointed him as a
prophet
when he recited to him the first verses
of surat
and the story that we're all very
familiar with this is where ibn
al-qayyam picks up
and he goes and continues until the end
and the death of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
so usually when we look at zadil ma'ad
it's usually been printed in five
volumes five volumes
there's been a sixth volume that has
been added later on
okay it's been usually been printed in
five volumes
and we can roughly
divide these volumes as follows
the first volume deals with
the first pillars of islam
which is how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam prayed which is where
we're
at as well as fasting and
atikaf etc the second volume usually
deals with
zakah and hajj
volume usually would be
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
sira
after prophethood and
the fourth volume is the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's medicine
right
and then the fifth volume is usually
dealing with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's judgments any time
there was a dispute
any time there was an issue historically
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
how he dealt with those disputes
whatever they may be
and then the sixth volume is usually
extensive index right extensive index
and
specific tables of contents
this is usually been how it's printed
and so
a book that many of us are familiar with
is the book of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's
medicine this book that
most popularly
circulated in america or in
english-speaking countries is the
darussalam
this is taken from the book
it's not an independent book that ibn
kalyan authored
rather it is the book
that is the usually the fourth volume
of zed in which
deals with in detail the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's medicine
all of the ways that he would deal with
anything having to do with the physical
body or
ailments ailments of the heart ailments
of the mind
illnesses of the body everything
right and it's also in alphabetical
order
he placed a large portion of it this is
usually housed in
has been divided up by publishers when
they print this book
it's also been printed in three volumes
it's also been condensed into one volume
and it has been a reference
its inception has been a reference for
the scholars of islam
whenever you hear that
a scholar will say and the author of a
zed
the author of the provisions has
whenever you read this they are
referring to
allah and they are referring more
specifically to his books
now this book
has a huge topic as we just heard it's a
book that's divided up into all these
different categories
and deals with so much and that is that
you take something the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sunnah all of his words
all of his
actions all of his statements and they
are extremely broad they span
across 23 years okay
and if you would notice with me that a
lot of
information was collected about the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in his lifetime by the companions
because he's not any other man
and he is most relevant so everything
having to do with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
was documented meticulously organized
and scrutinized
and so a breath that he took
essentially was recorded in one way
every movement every statement every use
of words
the way he sat the way he spoke the way
he walked the way he looked
the way that he looked at others the way
that others looked at him
the way that he interacted with various
that he interacted with animals or
children or the different sexes or the
different religions or
cetera et cetera all of this has been
meticulously
painstakingly documented
right and scrutinized and poured over by
the scholars of islam
and rightfully so so if you have
something
this vast right
and our religion of course when it comes
to
rulings and laws and details of those
laws
there is nasa in mansur and
there are things that are general things
that are specific
things that are incidental things that
are isolated things that
there's a lot of things that occur and
they these things have to be
categorized and deciphered by the
scholars of islam it is a huge
monumental and daunting task and so
when you look at something that a
body of
information so vast right and collected
from so many different people so many
different perceptions
right in order to harmonize all of that
information
put it into order in order
sequence meaning in order of
historically what happened when
and also to harmonize
amongst the general and specific
the isolated and the habitual
the incidental and the intentional etc
etc all of these things which are
things that categories of islam that
need to be
taken into consideration we see that it
is a
huge huge huge monumental task
right huge and monumental task
that the scholars of islam have
undertaken and harmonize
all of this information and so a book
zad al-ma'ad is invaluable
because not only does it comprise all of
that stuff
and not only does it put all of these
things
into sequential order but he also
harmonizes
all of this information meaning this and
this seem to be
contradicting but actually this means
this and this means that this is
something that has been abrogated and
this is something that
is affirmed this is something general
this is specific this is isolated and
this is habitual this is
etc that's a huge amount of information
and only the most elite of scholars
historically have been able to do this
right
and so this is why many
scholars make a distinction between
the sunnah and the hadith
right what does that mean there's a
difference between hadith and sunnah yes
subtle difference and that is that
every sunnah is is a hadith but not
every hadith is a sunnah if you think
about it in that way
what does that mean well there are
things that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said or things that he
did
or things that he affirmed or things
that he allowed
or things that he encouraged etc etc
however not all of those things are
necessarily legislation for
every single person there are things
that are to be taken
taken into consideration right in the
broader scheme of things
and so this is where scholarship comes
into
comes into play where we have books of
hadith
that document his the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam statements
they document the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam's actions
they document all of these things but
they don't necessarily
make complete sense of everything this
is left for scholars so
if we take a book sunan abi dawud
it is
filled to the brim with narrations
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
narrations of his statements or his acts
but not every single thing that is found
in sunan
dawud is necessarily a sunnah for
everybody at every time there are things
that have been abrogated there are
things that have been
that have been
redone by the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam there are isolated incidents
etc and this is why we say scholarship
is so important many people say well you
know what's what's the big deal about
a scholar they can read a book we can
read a book
they are literate we are literate just
as literature and that is
the statement of someone who has no idea
of the sheer amount of
information that is available
takes a very very unique and special
scholar
to be able to harmonize all of this
information
right and so
as we said this is an important
principle for us to understand and that
is
hadith
everything that he would habitually do
and intended be
done by people who witnessed him do this
all of that falls into the general
meaning of hadith
but not every hadith is necessarily a
sunnah
right because of the reasons that we
have just
proposed and so that is why a book like
monumental is so important historically
because it's not easy to harmonize all
of that
information it takes a lot of knowledge
very special kind of person to be able
to
understand things and so
as was alluded to by imam
that he mentioned i have believed in
allah
and what has come to me and what has
come to us from allah
allah and i have believed in these
things
as allah intended and i have believed in
the messenger of allah
i believe in everything that has come to
us from the messenger of allah
in the way that the messenger of allah
intended
right so understanding yeah everybody
will understand
but it's only scholarship
only the scholars of islam that have
taken
things traditionally
with a chain of narration reaching back
into the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's time only they
understand
things as they were intended to be
understood
you can open the quran and understand
whatever you like
and actually the quran is just vague
enough that you will be able to
make it say or understand it to say
anything you want
and it's also just specific enough that
it will guide you in a very specific way
if you
allow it to however
understanding the quran is not the issue
the issue is
understanding the quran
properly understanding the quran
in the way that allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
meant for it to be understood that's a
whole different
thing there's only one understanding
with regards to that
and so a lot of people will say you know
oh the quran is
you know it says this and it says
that and
you know people will say things and a
lot of these things that they say are
absurd
in a lot of times but they will use the
quran as an
evidence to that absurdity and we will
say
yes anybody can twist the words of the
quran to mean whatever they want it to
mean
but only a very particular type of
people will understand the quran
as allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala intended
as the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
and his companions
understood the quran there is only one
mutual unanimous understanding
to the basics and the fundamentals of
the quran and that is found with the
companions of
and so people
will murder they will
pillage people will even
rape they will destroy
they will steal they will do all of
these terrible things
and they will use evidence to justify
these actions
from the quran yes they will use
historically the most murderous of
people have used the quran as
evidence for their
atrocities but it doesn't mean that the
quran says that
they twisted it to mean that right
and so on and so forth so this is why
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala describes the
quran
as clear and explicit in the chess
and in the hearts of those who have been
given knowledge he says
he says that which translates to
the quran is clear explicit
evidences in the chess in the hearts
of those who have been given knowledge
it's only
very particular people who have that
knowledge and that is the scholarship of
islam
who a trace back
their knowledge that they have inherited
all the way back to the mouth and the
body
and the soul of the prophet
this is muhammad important introduction
because
when we see a lot of
differing amongst people we have to
understand that this differing
exists mainly in the minds of people
it is not differing or discrepancies
found in the quran rather the litmus
test of the quran that it gives us
is a
do they not contemplate deeply and
reflect on the meanings in the quran
and and come to the realization that had
it been from anyone other than allah
they would find much discrepancy in it
in the quran so allah subhanahu was
added challenges everyone
to read through the quran to study it
and reflect on its meanings
deeply and that if a person does this
with
honesty they will not find any
contradiction therein
not just the quran but the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam as well
and so this is why
this book is so special and this is why
this book holds such a
such a special place in the hearts of
and in the hearts and in the minds of
the scholars of islam
and the islamic library
he says that this chapter is regarding
the traditions and the habits of the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam on the day of jumu'
and this chapter also deals with
the particulars and the unique
aspects of the day of jumu'
that have been mentioned by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he opens this chapter by saying
[Silence]
in this narration he says allah
had obscured the day of jumu'
from those nations that have preceded us
and so the jews for them was the day of
saturday and for the christians the day
of
sunday and allah created us
and this nation and he guided us
and manif made manifest to us
the day of jumu' and so
those are the three days that were
ordained
the day of jumu' the day of saturday
and the day of sunday he says
and this is how it will be as well
on the day of resurrection that the
nations will
all follow our lead on that day
we are the last of the people of the
earth
of humanity this nation is the last
nation
and we are the first of nations
and at the forefront of nations on the
day of resurrection
and we will be the ones to be judged
before
all other all other nations
this is a very powerful narration
speaking about the
importance of the day of jumuah
that the day of friday
it is the day that allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
of the week has appointed and given
most virtue to because
yes all of the days are days
essentially 24 hours but
not every day is the same allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala chooses
of his creation what he what he
will subhanahu ta'ala and so yes there
is humanity
but then allah chooses an anoints from
amongst humanity the prophets and from
amongst the prophets the messengers
from amongst the messengers the most
important and supreme of messengers
etcetera etcetera
likewise is the issue with the months of
the year and likewise the issue with the
days of the week and so the most
virtuous of days
is the day of jumu' this is the most
however the people of
moses of musa they were not given
the day of jumu' as their day of of
celebration amongst the week they were
appointed the day of
saturday and the christians the people
of isa
as well they were not given
the day of jumu' which is the most
virtuous of days
rather they were given the day of sunday
and the people of muhammad sallallahu
this nation anyone that follows the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and he is their prophet
that nation this nation has been given
the most virtuous of days
which is the day of jumu' right
what does that mean what does that mean
does this mean that the people who
were the people of musa alaihis
salaam
who exalted the day of saturday
that they were wrong for doing so and
that this was an innovation
no that's not what is intended because
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded them to observe
the sabbath which is the day of sabbath
and sabbat in the arabic language
articulates cutting something
and that is that they were cut off from
their
daily activities and their work on that
day they were to observe the sabbath
there's no working on that day there's
no hunting on that day there's no
fishing on that day
right and allah said to them
he said to them subhanahu wata'ala
commanded them
do not transgress on that day of
sabbath the day of sabbath the day of
saturday right and then we have
stories of their transgressions on that
day of sabbath
and it's also historically mentioned in
the ten
commandments that were given to muslim
and one of them was remember the sabbath
keep it holy
right and so likewise we have with the
day of sunday
it doesn't mean that these days are not
virtuous they are virtuous but they are
not the most virtuous
the most virtuous of days is the day of
friday
and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala appointed
the day of friday which is the most
virtuous
for this ummah for this ummah of the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam this was not something
that was given to any nation
before it was
it it is this nation and so just as
friday precedes sun saturday
and just as friday hence therefore
precedes sunday likewise this nation
will precede other nations on the day of
resurrection
we are the last of nations but we are
the first of nations
as the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us in this narration
and so
the virtue of the day of jumu' is the
most
virtuous and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
had legislated
and guided this nation specifically
to the exaltation and the celebration of
that day of jummah
right now
continues on and you know a person may
say
well why what is the reason that allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala chose this nation
over
others and the answer to that
is twofold the most
important is
that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
the quran
he says that is the
virtue of your lord it is to his
discretion
and he
and he distributes that virtue
as he sees fit and as he chooses
and allah is ever vast and all
knowledgeable subhana and so this refers
back to thee this refers back to the
will of allah subhanahu wazada and the
discretion of allah
secondly the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
explain this to us to an extent
in sahih al-bukhari and sahih al-bukhari
in the book of
or the chapter times of prayer
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was narrated therein to have mentioned
that the example the parable of this
ummah
with the nations that preceded it
of judaism and christianity
is a man who hired some people to
do
some work for him so he hired
a lot of people a lot meaning a group of
people
he hired them to work
from the beginning of the day until the
middle of the day until
and he gave them their reward
their pay but they were unable to
complete the work
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
and said
and then he hired another group
another lot of people
and he had them work
and promised them a certain
payment for their troubles and for their
work
and they continued to work from the
middle of
until the evening time
but they were unable to complete the
work
and so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
terrible here the man gave these people
their pay and then he hired
another group of people to complete the
day's work
from early evening until sunset
and they completed the work
and he gave them their pay and he gave
them
extra and gave them a bonus on top of
their pay
and so the other two nations that came
before the third
said we worked longer and we were paid
less
and so this man said to them
have i prohibited you or depre
of your pay have i wronged you in any
way
they said no but you gave them extra
more than
us but you did pay us completely fairly
for
the work that we did he said
he said that is it's my money and i can
give it to whomever i
choose this man says in this analogy
and so likewise is the analogy of this
nation here this nation of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
this last nation of muhammad allah
that the the the people that
came before us the people of musa
and the jews and the people that came
after him and before us the christians
they are the second group in this
analogy right
and they were all paid and given
they what they excuse me what they were
owed
in full yet allah brought this nation
they work the least but they are given
the most
and they are favored and endowed by
allah for reasons that
refer back to the wisdom and knowledge
and discretion of allah subhanahu wazada
he did not wrong those nations that
preceded us
but he did give this nation the
best of what any nation could have hoped
to receive we have the best of
books we have the best of prophets
we have the most numbers we have been
given the most
knowledge we have been given the most
revelation
etcetera etcetera and so
what is the reason for this that is the
discretion of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
all of this virtue belongs to he and it
is to his discretion
alone without any partners
and your lord creates whatever he
chooses
he is the one who chooses and it is to
his discretion
meaning to give virtue to that creation
or to whomever
from amongst that creation that he
chooses
it is not for them to
or it is not to their discretion
and allah rather it is to the discretion
of allah subhanahu wa
and so we see here that this is
a very particular virtue that allah has
given to this nation amongst others
continues on and he says
also collected and authenticated on the
authority
of who narrates that the prophet
the best and most virtuous of days that
the sun has ever risen upon
is the day of jumu' the day of friday
adam on the day of friday
adam alaihissalam the first human being
was created
and on that day of jumu' he was
admitted into paradise
and on a friday he was expelled from
paradise as well
and the hour will not be established
until the except on a day of jumoah
meaning on the day of jumu' it all
began
and on the day of jumu' it will all
come to an
end and the day of judgment will
commence on the day of jumu'
we will leave off here with that
and we will continue next week
insha'allah in the
virtues of the day of jummah
and the starting or continuing next
week insha'allah